people of the state of colorado versus
ahmad al-ali
al-issa can i have the appearance of
counsel for the people please pleased
morning honor michael doherty and ken
kufner on behalf of the people of the
state of colorado
good morning and for the defendant good
morning your honor katherine harold
daniel king and sam dunn on behalf of mr
alisa who is president
good morning council good morning mr
alisa sir you're here for an advisement
here and i need to advise you of your
rights pursuant to rule five
you need to understand that you need to
make no statements and any statement
that you do make
uh can and may be used against you you
have the right to counsel in this case
the office of the public defender has
been appointed to represent you
any plea that you make must be voluntary
and cannot be the result of undue
influence or coercion
you have the right to bail if the
offense is available right now you're
being held without bail
mr dougherty do the people anticipate
seeking the determination that the proof
is evident and the consumption is great
yes sean thank you mr alisa what that
means is you'll be held without bail
until such time as the court is able to
determine whether or not the proof is
evident and the presumption is great
that you committed
these crimes you have the right to be
informed of the nature of the charges
you have the right to a jury trial and
you have the right to man
to demand and receive a pulling our
hearing within a reasonable time
to determine whether probable cause
exists
and if you're currently serving in the
united states armed forces or if you're
a veteran of such forces
you may be entitled to receive mental
health treatment substance use disorder
treatment
or other services as a veteran
sir do you understand those rights as
i've explained them to you this morning
i need you to answer out loud yes okay
and for the record he answered
affirmatively
uh the people have filed a complaint and
information
uh charging 11 counts ms harold on
behalf of the defendant will you
acknowledge receipt of the complaint and
information
waive formal reading and further
advisement yes your honor
all right we need to set this matter for
a hearing on
proof evidence presumption great along
with the preliminary hearing
uh what's the defense's uh thoughts with
respect to how soon we can set that
hearing
your honor we would be requesting at
this time that we actually set a status
prior to studying the proof of evidence
great hearing
our position is that we cannot do
anything until we are able to
fully assess mr alisa's mental illness
we cannot begin to assess the nature and
depth of mr elisa's
mental illness until we have the
discovery from the government
it's my understanding that the
government is continuing to investigate
this case
the discovery is going to be voluminous
and so at this juncture it doesn't make
sense to set the proof evident
presumption great here
so we'd be requesting
and so is your client willing to waive
his right to preliminary hearing within
35 days to accommodate that or a later
setting for preliminary hearing and
proof evidence presumption greater